kunst gerät in bewegung
oder trifft kultur schafft 21 schweizer
gegenwartskünstler befassen sich mit der
sammlung außereuropäischer kunst
reagieren mit eigenen auf die alten
meister aus fernen ländern
was hat diese fremdartige kunst und
schweizern zu sagen
glücklicherweise muss man kein fachmann
sein um mit diesen werken etwas anfangen
zu können wo es berührt und die haltung
von unterwegs kulturchef endpreis und
praxis ich finde die bald umziehen
wie es aber heuer gestartet
die ewig reisenden in der installation
der künstlergruppe park noah sie soll
darauf aufmerksam machen dass fremdheit
auch eine chance ist anders funktioniert
das system dann das eigene system neu
auch wie man im vergleich hat und ich
werde das immer wieder darauf sich auf
kunst gemacht wird und dass man
plötzlich in sich selber ganz
unterschiedlich reagieren die künstler
auf die rietberg sammlung farbig
geometrisch wieder wie trinken oder über
das gehör
diese lima naja fichte wird verkabelt
denn in der installation von peter regli
sind sie ein freund aus butter
in der villa wesendonck gleich nebenan
einer videoinstallation von pipilotti
rist
eine japanischen omas gedient als
projektionsfläche und veranschaulicht
wie außereuropäische kunst für westliche
projektionen herhalten muss
neben diesem gastspiel der schweizer
künstler beherbergt das riedberg museum
im moment eine weitere ausstellung jene
des japanischen zentrist us-sänger
pipilotti rist schon lange fasziniert
von japan besucht diese ausstellung
gemeinsam mit der kuratorin katharina
precht
das sei der unkonventionellen künstler
hätte wohl nicht auf andächtige stille
gepocht er war ein freigeist
das verbindet ihn mit heutigen künstler
in bar auszahlte reduzierten prozent ist
aber dass gemaltes tisch und sein
meister werden und kühl freispruch
und das machten
somit folgt die reduktion die
bescheidenheit nicht mit dem humor ich
hoffe du mich so wie ich wusste dass ich
in der nacht träum ich sogar japanerin
und im besten fall denn direkt einfluss
auf die arbeit in der maximierung zum
minimum der künstler yves netzhammer
beschäftigt sich statt mit reduktion mit
der fülle dichter stress im schaulager
des museums was wenn wir uns die
ausstellung zielt mitten in eine
gesellschaftliche debatte
ganz im sinne von damian christina
kurator der gast vorstellen wenn ich
sehe dass fremde ein großes thema
das sind eigentlich für überfremdet
initiativen oder erfinde gedichte
straßen mal die geschichte wurde in der
spitze wichtiger zwickl und was jetzt
mit dem fremde und das museum ist muss
im lehrter metall historische tief ich
kann vielleicht ganz kleiner raum haben
dass wir das bewusst werden wir mehr mit
den veränderungen
das